THE SEVERE LOWS ARE PRESENT TO
YOU AS PROOF OF GLOBAL
BUT FIRST REPUBLICANS IN
CONGRESS ARE DEMANDING AN
INVESTIGATION IN TO
CHRISTOPHER STEEL, THE AUTHOR
OF THE INFAMOUS TRUMP DOSSIER
CORRESPONDENT IS ALL OVER
THIS.
>> THIS IS THE FIRST CRIMINAL
REFERRAL FROM CONGRESS AS PART
OF THE RUSSIAN INVESTIGATION.
THE REPUBLICAN CHAIRMAN CHUCK
GRASSLEY WHO HAS OVERSIGHT TO
THE F.B.I., JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
WITH LINDSEY GRAHAM BELIEVES
THERE IS A VIOLATION OF LYING
STATUTE.
ACCORDING TO THE LETTER MADE
PUBLIC TODAY, THEY BELIEVE
STEEL DISTRIBUTION OF THE
UNVERIFIED TRUMP DOSSIER AND
HALF A DOZEN MEDIA OUTLETS
WERE BRIEFED BEFORE THE
ELECTION.
HE WAS -- IN THE MONTHS
LEADING UP TO THE ELECTION HE
TOLD STEEL TO BRIEF REPORTERS
TWICE AFTER NO REPORTERS RAN
WITH THE STORY.
THE PROJECT FUNDEDDY THE
HE SAYS IT'S ABOUT A PERCEIVED
DOUBLE STANDARD WHEN THE TRUMP
ASSOCIATES WERE PROSECUTED FOR
LYING TO THE F.B.I.
TONIGHT A SENIOR SENATE
DEMOCRAT CALLED IT PARTISAN